>> I think India is already an economic power.
It depends what the definition of superpower,
I think the world has
changed, definitely the global economies [INAUDIBLE]
is moving east.
But still, [INAUDIBLE] Europe and other countries
but definitely
chances of different stage of growth or development
India has big
potential to grow and will grow [INAUDIBLE]
to China.
Whether we are going to have one superpower,
I doubt it.
I think we're going to have almost always
more than one part of the
world recovering maybe their position in their
part of the world.
At the end of the day, they're all interrelated.
We cannot survive to have the state position
for long.
Even India will be [INAUDIBLE].
I think we have a global economy everybody
else depends on us.
But there will be more than one superpower
in the future and it's
already started I think.